Are you familiar with what's going on with Patrion with a,
and that's like the podcast pay for him or you can pay for shit with Patriana.
Well,
yeah,
you can pay for things,
but it's not necessarily just for podcasts,
but people do use it for podcasts,
but we use it for many things.
Okay.
But there's this guy,
his name is Carl Benjamin,
and he goes by the name of Sargon are our cod and he considers himself a,
what did you call a classic British liberal,
which is more leans,
more conservative than our idea of what a liberal is.
But essentially it's more of a like a libertarian.
Toward what,
how would you,
how would you describe a classic British liberal?
Like what would be the definitely Google that the front of the name would be
Carl Benjamin.
I mean,
that's a strong name.
Well,
Sargon of cod.
His,
his,
uh,
his screen name and he has a youtube channel.
And uh,
he said something on a podcast,
not even a zone.
He was a guest on another channel and he said something about white supremacist.
He was talking about these white supremacists that are acting up and doing all
these horrible things.
And he said,
and this is,
it's a poorly formed thought,
but what he essentially said was,
you guys are being niggers almost.
You act like white niggers.
This is his word,
cheesy.
See this is what he's saying.
You're acting like a bunch of niggers.
Just so you know,
you act like white niggers.
I'm sorry if you heard that word.
And so offending you right now,
ladies and gentlemen,
I'm just reading exactly how you described black people acting is the impression
I get dealing with the alt right.
I'm really,
I'm just not in the mood to deal with this kind of disrespect.
So that's a very,
very shy,
it's a very poorly thought out way of expressing himself.
Um,
that's what I'm thinking.
I'm reading this and I think also sometimes people like using that word to shock
and they think they can get away with it.
And you know,
when you're using it,
what's this?
What's this and what's the context of this?
Like what is it?
But you also said,
here,
look,
you carry on,
but you don't expect me to have a debate with one of your faggots.
Like why would I bother?
Okay,
now that is more egregious because that is,
I mean,
and if you're,
you're just dealing with censoring words.
There's not,
he's not using that saying you're acting like the way you call gay people.
He's not saying that.
He's like calling someone a gay slur and he sang it again and again.
So this was just what they had decided to use.
Now I don't agree with any of these things.
He said,
this is what I'm reading this.
I'm like,
this is,
these are poorly thought out arguments.
This is a poorly thought out sentence.
It's not,
well just stop scrolling there for a second.
Put that back up.
It's not,
it's not well thought out.
Not at all.
Not Good.
So they've,
but this has nothing to do with his patrion page.
It doesn't even have to do with his,
his channel.
This is something,
he made this comment as a part of a longer wide ranging interview with a
youtuber named Michelle Kaitlin Catlin.
And you can watch the full interview on this.
It says chatting with Sargon of a cod about the liberalist community.
Um,
so he,
you know,
it was free flowing any,
he said a bunch of really stupid things that,
but what he was trying to say is that these people are behaving exactly the way
they do when they try to say racist things about black people.
Essentially they're are behaving exactly the way they're describing race in a
racist way.
Yeah.
It's just not well thought out.
I mean this guy needs a class and how to fucking be articulate.
I mean,
Jesus Christ.
But that's,
that's what I'm getting from this patron decided to remove him because of that.
And there's many people that feel like that's not exactly why they did it,
that they were looking for an excuse.
And it's really because of his anti liberal bias.
So they will,
a lot of people are disgusted by the idea that Patrion is now censoring voices
and the deciding who should or should not be able to receive donations from
their fans based on their own personal political biases.
So this is the argument now and it's a,
it's an interesting thing that's popped up because people like Sam Harris who is
very left,
I mean he gets accused of being all right,
which is kind of hilarious,
but he's very progressive and you know he's a public intellectual and he's
decided that this is a moment where he is going to pull his patriotic countdown
because he doesn't like the way they are choosing to censor people and d
platform people based entirely on something that has nothing to do with anything
he's done on their platform and has something to do with something that was out
there on a,
on another channel.
So it's one of those weird little battleground situations.
Do think like a patient has a private enterprise,
right?
Yes.
So they can do whatever the fuck they want.
They essentially they can and did it.
So then people can decide that they don't want to deal with Patrion because
Patriot doesn't support free speech,
free speech.
The argument would go that free speech is not just supporting speech,
that you agree with it.
True.
Free speech is letting people express themselves.
Right now,
the way he expressed himself,
they're not very good,
clumsy,
right?
Heavy.
That's an understatement though.
Like your thoughts on it this year,
you've never seen this before.
What are your thoughts on it?
I'm like,
dude,
Jews.
I mean it's such a,
that choice of words is such a way
to just,
if I'm,
if I'm person reading that,
unlike my immediate,
my eye goes,
you said what you can't,
like,
it's such an offensive word where you can't even go there immediately distracts
from the point that you're trying to make.
So it's a good way of putting it.
You know?
It's,
it's such like a,
you just need it.
You need like,
I don't think that guy,
I don't know if he's racist or not,
but like I don't think he is.
But your immediate reaction is like this guy,
you can't do that.
You have,
you have fundamentally destroyed whatever point you were trying to make because
of your choice.
It's like a,
you could be trying to save,
I can't think of the analogy now,
but like it's,
it's such a distracting choice of words.
That's a great way of putting it.
You know,
he could've said,
and by the way,
like all conversations including this one,
right?
Like I'm trying to formulate these opinions on the fly.
So are you,
yeah,
that was what he was doing on the fly.
I don't think there's anything he prepared.
Sorry.
Damn dog.
You mean that wasn't vetted?
Oh Dude,
he's gone over that with a fucking highlighter is the key points and once I hit
on,
it must have been a few websites.
I don't know.
No,
no.
I was trying to look up the ones exactly,
but I know for instance on twitch in the last year they've changed things on the
terms of service that kind of what you do broadly yes.
Affects what you do on anyone's account.
Problem with that.
What you're just saying right now is the guy who's a CEO of Patriot actually win
on Dave Rubin's show,
the Rubin report and said that they're only concerned with things that happen on
Patrion is that that's what they focus on.
Then they changed that after this because here's the problem,
like I see their point with this,
this particular thing that this guy said.
I see.
How they find that offensive and if that becomes a thing that he does more than
once and becomes a thing that he uses that all the time and uses that kind of
that kind of language in that context a lot.
It's like,
hmm,
this is not,
it's clunky.
It's not,
it's not a wise choice of words.
It's,
it's,
it's sloppy and it's kind of lazy.
Right.
And also it's kind of racist,
but it's why is it racist?
Well,
it's racist because what he's doing is attacking people who are racists by
saying,
and he could have done it this way,
right?
He could have said you people rally on about black people and call them this and
you say they're doing that.
This is what you do,
right?
You are exactly what you're,
the only thing that's missing is that you don't have the right pigment to,
to receive your own,
hate your own self,
hate what you're doing.
The very things that you accuse that you in a racist way accused black people of
doing.
It's stupid.
But it's the way to combat that.
I eat when you start censoring people and taking away their ability to make a
living by expressing themselves.
I just don't think that's the way to go because you're just going to receive
backlash and that's,
that's the thing.
It's one of those that's,
that's one of those instances where it's like you've set a trigger word that is
clearly a trigger word and what you just said is the way he should have said
what he wanted to say.
Right.
And in hindsight,
if you gave them an opportunity,
like you say,
Hey Carl,
here's a time machine or I go back right before you said that and say it again.
What I'll just say I'm Patriot on the,
like I,
I'm reading their stance on it as a website.
They don't host anything.
So like to say that it's something that's happening.
History logs,
like Jordan Peterson wrote a blog on Patrion,
but that's what most of their content is,
is links from other websites.
They have to take into account what you're creating as a creator anywhere
almost,
right.
This isn't the whole argument of him as a creator though.
This was him.
A guest on someone else's show.
So this is not something he,
that's his own content that he put out their stances that he collaborates with
other creators and this,
this would be considered a collaboration.
Yeah,
I see that point.
I do not think that it's a wise thing to censor him though.
Do you ah,
get that mother Fucker,
a PR coach dog with Jesus Christ.
The very least.
Maybe that this is the first dance,
which I think they're saying it is a definitely a warning or maybe,
yeah.
But here's the thing,
man.
Here's the fan temporary ban.
Here's the thing.
What he does is he's,
uh,
he's,
he's a commentator.
He sees his life and he talks about it and I've listened to a lot of his stuff
and it's very good.
He's a,
he's a smart man and a lot of it's very good.
This is not very good.
So the right way when it comes to these things is let the people who contribute
to his patron decide that they don't like what he's doing.
So they're are no longer going to subscribe.
That's the correct use of the platform.
The platform exists because people who are fans are able to contribute that.
I say new mash,
I really like what you do.
I'm going to send you $100 every month.
And if someone wants to do that,
they can do that.
And there's a lot of people that do do that.
When you say something that makes them offended,
that makes him realize you're sloppy with your words,
that makes him feel like you're a fool.
They go,
you know what,
I'm not sending that fucking guy money and the marketplace talking about,
and then they pull back.
If you lost 30% of his market because of that,
and then a bunch of blogs are written about how stupid what he said was,
that's the correct response.
Correct.
I think,
I don't think po,
but the problem with pulling out is then guys like Sam Harris or pulling out and
they've lost somewhere around 20% of all their patriotic accounts because of
this.
Oh,
she goes,
there's been a backlash.
And by the way,
a backlash that's primarily coming from people who don't agree with what that
guy said,
but do agree that it's a very slippery slope to start censoring people.
That's a good moral stance to take.
Like,
uh,
it's like Kinda like I,
I forget which political figures said,
I was like,
I do not agree with what you're saying,
but I will die.
Defend,
fight to the the day your ability to see the ability to say yes.
I think that's,
it's important because the only way that ideas get worked out is through
discussion.
And as soon as you silenced voices,
then you no longer have that discussion.
Now,
to Youtube's credit,
he still up on Youtube.
Okay.
Cause this was a talk that he had that's available on Youtube.
You can listen to it on youtube.
He still has his youtube account and he's still able to.